into it let's start with a marriage
between John and Dana Targaryen people
have been shipping this tool since the
very beginning of the series we had all
known that at some point John and Annie
would meet each other and eventually
fall in love Game of Thrones Season
seven did finally see Ice and Fire come
together as John and Danny finally met
and promptly fell in love since then he
did not come to Westeros only conquer it
but also to build a stable order and
reunite all the semi kingdoms of each
monster in an open rebellion against the
crown Jon Snow was and still is the only
logical sewer for Dany John and Danny
have already began an intimate
relationship although near one of them
is currently aware of their family ties
since John and Danny are headed to
Winterfell it's likely that brain stem
will reveal the truth about Joshu
heritage early on in season clearly this
revelation of Danny being John's aunt
will come as a huge shock to both of
them and will most certainly affect
their relationship even though it's a
Shias pairings have never bought a
Targaryen sand some might even say that
it will not bother John or Danny as well
since their Targaryen themselves you
might be wrong Targaryen did spend over
300 years reading brother to sister in
order to keep their bloodline pure
that's affect then his parents urged
Matt King and trial of her siblings and
Danny did grow up believing should marry
her brother Viserys also true but this
simply is not the same
even though intermarriage is accepted in
Westeros and expected for Targaryen John
was not raised as a Targaryen and likely
will not embrace their family traditions
throughout the series it has been
established that first-degree incest
outside of the Targaryen family such as
crest and his daughters and of course
the most popular incest couple Jamie and
Cersei is considered wrong and immoral
intermarriage between first cousins on
the other hand is not considered incest
in Westeros society a prominent example
of this system Lannister who married his
own cousin Joanna Lannister mother of
all three of his children however John
and Danny are not cousins nor their
siblings their nephew intent and
therefore many have been wondering if
they will upon finding out the truth
still marry each other to seal their
alliance in my opinion there will be the
Targaryen marriage but they will not
marry in order to seal their alliance
but rather because of their child
I doubt John and Danny will continue
their intimate relationship after they
find out the truth but the fact is that
they will find out the truth a bit too
late as in my opinion Dany already got
pregnant in a season 7 finale I can't
have children who told you that
don't you related my husband hasn't
occurred to you she might not have been
a reliable source of information
despite n is believed that she cannot
have children because of the prophecy
that was told to her by the wage that
killed her husband then it will most
likely be pregnant with John's baby the
next time we see her just as John Snow
stated it's highly possible that the
witch was not being honest with Danny
which along with a lot of her shadows
that took place in the previous season
might mean that the season finale brings
more surprises than we hoped for once
they learn of their family ties the
other news will hidden they already
mentioned Annie's pregnancy vigils baby
and that exact news will make them
change their mind and even though
they're related they will decide to
marry each other and here's why John has
been a bastard son his entire life and
he must surely not allow his child to be
born out of wedlock and live a life he's
been living both in the book series and
on the show genuine itial refuses to
sleep with women because he's absolutely
terrified that he might produce a
bastard the fact that John himself is
not actually a bastard but legitimate
son of Rhaegar Targaryen and Lyanna
Stark and true heir to the Iron Throne
is highly ironic of course but it
doesn't change the way he grew up it
most definitely will not change his
desire not to bring another bastard
named snow into the world
therefore this marriage of Ice and Fire
does not come as a huge surprise take
into consideration that Dane is most
likely pregnant and John on the other
hand would never allow his child to be
born out of wedlock this Targaryen baby
was heavily foreshadowed throughout the
previous season that most fans have
already accepted his theories effect
it's been foreshadowed vision statement
that Danny barely can have a child
despite the witch prophecy and with
Tyrion and dense conversation but her
plan for succession beside any becoming
a matter Justin becoming a fighter has
also been for shared of the few times
with most prominent fun being a
conversation between John and Jorah
about John's future child in season 7
episode 6 John offers Longclaw and Jorah
declines to the statement it's yours
mate serve you well and your children
after you now let's take a look on
another Royal Wedding that has also been
hinted and foreshadowed many times
throughout both the books and the show
fans have been theorizing that ginjury
sudden reappearance in season 7 might
have something to do with the fact that
Granger's particular set of skills could
be helpful if they ever worked out how
to forge more Valyrian steel swords more
importantly some fans heavy of Ginja
being back on the scene as a sign that
his fighters promised Ned Stark in
season 1 might finally be fulfilled we
were meant to rule together if your
sister had lived
would have been bound by blood well it's
not too late I have a son you have a
daughter will join our houses Robert was
talking about Joffrey who he thought was
his son and Ned's daughter Sansa this
never happened and therefore House Stark
and house Baratheon haven't been joined
yet
however huge amount offense things that
this marriage might finally happen in
the form of Roberts only son ginjury and
Ned's daughter Arya orange injury formed
a special bond way back when they were
traveling to get her north in the Kings
Road there's one memorable scene that
Orion Ginja shared that might a
foreshadow that those two could become
family one day
let's take a look he's been a brother's
family
and never had a family
I can be your family
it wouldn't be my family
you'd be milady
ginjury begged and believed that him and
Arya could never be together considering
that she's a highborn daughter of Lord
Eddard Stark while he on the other hand
is just a bastard son of a random man or
at least that's what he thought he was
back then
ginger later found out who his father is
King Robert Baratheon having in mind
that our days at Winterfell while Ginji
on the other hand is heading towards
that vigil so in the near star garyun
those two almost certainly reunite in
the final season while many fans believe
our leg injury will end up together many
fans are also convinced that Arya could
never settle down and had children after
all that's what I just said herself
regarding her future you will marry a
high Lord and rule his castle and your
son's shall be knights and princes and
Lords however what we also need to
understand is that Game of Thrones is
full of irony sense of the proper lady
who wanted to marry a prince sent him
any children we know what happened to
those dreams a marriage her throats
tightened she did not want to Wed again
not now perhaps not ever sends his
thoughts in a feast for crows the point
is that are you never going to be a lady
while her sister says Salva dreamed of
marrying a handsome young man giving him
children and living a happy life
wouldn't it be ironic seeing Arya who
never wanted any of that getting what
sense of its bond it will expect Arya to
either die in a battle or to live out
her days as an assassin adventurer and
that's why neither this will happen it
would be too obvious her getting a happy
ending and living her life as a proper
lady she never wanted to be will be a
huge twist for a character or is a
highly trained assassin with a thirst
for vengeance however at this point are
already avenged her family and when the
war is over and the White Walkers are
defeated I think the target will get a
live sense I used to dream of and
ironically Arya will enjoy that life or
it will most likely end up marrying
injury and live out her days raising
their children in the castle I have a
son you have a daughter will join our
houses is the quote that has always been
on my mind this in my opinion
foreshadows Ginjo and are you joining
Baratheon and Stark houses once and for
all
some fans even claimed that George
Armand and showrunners thought of
re-injury while writing this particular
scene considering how they well to twist
words around
Arya resembles her aunt Lyanna stark
your hand appears to resemble his father
in a traverse their union can symbolize
lien and robert relationship and this
time it is not one-sided love as we all
know robert was betrothed to Liana but
it did not work out
however Robertson fulfilling the promise
made years ago between how stark a house
Baratheon seems fitting Aria does have
feelings for ginjury which was made
clear when she told him that he can be
her family now the tire has finally
returned to Winterfell and Ginji on the
other hand has not only returned to the
series but is also heading to Winterfell
it just seems they're meant to end up
together I can definitely see them
living their days out peacefully in
storms end with their children Wilson ed
was killed in season 1 which said of the
events for the series second at help but
think that netted for share of this
marriage when he told Aria that she will
marry a high Lord and rule his castle
this marriage has also made foreshadowed
by the Lannisters in the books while
having a conversation regarding the
Starks with hoster Jaime might have her
shared the marriage between ginjury and
Arya is that why you killed all the
Starks host her as Jaime not at all said
Jaime Lord Eddard's daughters live one
has just been fed the Eddard if the guts
ragout she'll forget she was a stark
she'll let some barely blacksmith Jaime
might have been wrong about Arya
forgetting she was a stark but the part
in which she ends up at blacksmith's
seems highly possible just as Robert won
back in the first season the house
Baratheon and Stark will probably join
through his son and its daughter just
naturally once he and Ned thought
they're heavy guys to royal weddings are
likely to happen in last season of Game
of Thrones both have been heavily hinted
and foreshadowed I'm here switch real
wedding would you like to see the most
so please share with me in the comment
section